I’ll be going into spoilers since Avatar
the Way of Water has been out for a couple
of weeks, so we can talk about the story in
detail.
Obviously, the biggest draw for this movie
is the visual side of production and that
is all outstanding.
I’m sure you’ve heard about that ad-nauseam
and there’s not much to add in that regard.
So despite looking at this movie from a negative
perspective, I don’t hate it by any means
and just want to open up a discussion about
the story.
The reason why I want to focus on the story
of Avatar: The Way of Water is because this
movie has been in development for over 10
years.
So surely in that time, the script should
be pretty rock solid, but that didn’t feel
like the case when watching it.
From there being rough dialogue, weird and
new story mechanics, some baffling plot points,
and an overall script that gives off the feeling
of James Cameron having free reign and no
higher-ups having the balls to address different
issues within the script.
I’ll bring up some examples for all these
points in a second and before doing that,
I want to draw a comparison to the first Avatar.
People have famously called the movie unoriginal
and was just Pocahontas but with Aliens.
However, because of that simple and effective
plot, it translated really well into this
new setting, and because of this, the first
Avatar wasn’t held back by the story.
This is where I think one of the major components
of Avatar the Way of Water feels off to me.
Because in the first movie, we had a compelling
protagonist go through a riveting adventure
laced with whimsical and exciting world-building
while being anchored by a strong love story.
Along with having a feeling of escapism through
Jake leaving his dour life on earth where
he can’t walk to a vibrant life on Pandora
in which he can transcend anything he could
do on earth.
It was very liberating in a way.
In the Way of Water, I feel like we are missing
this strong throughline that carries the movie.
The substitution here is Jake’s family,
but I don’t think it’s as strong as the
wonder-like awe the first Avatar was able
to capture.
That’s kind of here with the beautiful visuals
but not narratively.
The characters that we follow have very little
character development and the main emphasis
is on the spectacle.
To me, this creates a feeling of disconnection
because instead of having a symbiotic relationship
between dazzling visuals and good character
work, we instead have minimal character work
with a stronger emphasis on visuals.
During certain segments of the movie, it felt
like I was watching an hour-long version of
the ride Flight of Passage in Animal Kingdom.
It was more like an experience, rather than
an engrossing story.
And again, that experience was very fun, but
you don’t have to sacrifice the story and
just have scenes solely there for the sake
of spectacle, instead, you can do both like
in the first Avatar.
Another thing is that Jake Sully and Neytiri
take a back seat, and Neytiri more than jake
in that regard, so that their kids can take
center stage.
Now this would be fine in theory if the kids
were as interesting as Jake and Neytiri were
in the first movie.
To me, this isn’t the case.
Firstly, going back to the bad dialogue, Jake’s
kids are talking as if they are some weird
human kids who say Bro and Cuz in every other
sentence.
This was very jarring, to say the least, and
it doesn’t give off the notion that these
are Navi.
Now I know that they have a human father figure,
but I find it weird for Jake to teach his
Navi children human slang words, that not
even kids use that often.
It feels like James Cameron is out of touch
with how kids sound, let alone alien kids.
You’d think that Neytiri would want them
to be more skewed toward Navi culture and
would probably dislike that.
Then moving away from the dialogue, the kids
in most scenes didn’t come across as that
likable.
The two brothers had an extremely basic older/younger
brother dynamic and were constantly coming
across as arrogant.
That’s fine at times but when they are putting
themselves in mortal danger to the point where
they have to be saved in every other scene
then it becomes annoying narratively.
Like the kids were taken prisoner on like
3 separate occasions.
Once in the first act and then twice while
on the boat.
There was a point in the end where they were
like we have to intervene and they take their
youngest sibling with them for literally no
reason.
I was extremely confused by that decision
because she offers no value and they are unnecessarily
putting more of their family in danger.
The two child characters that I thought were
more interesting were Spider and Kiri.
For Kiri it was kind of hard for me to get
over the fact that she was being played by
a 73-year-old Sigourney Weaver, but she never
came across as overly annoying.
The mechanic where she can control certain
parts of the world of Pandora was a cool direction
to take her.
Then the inherent nature of Spider’s dynamic
of being a human raised by the Navi was fascinating.
Then to have him be captured by his resurrected
Avatar father Quaritch, throws on another
complex layer that in turn makes for some
good scenes.
The only issue here plot-wise for this character
is at the end of the movie.
Throughout the course of Spider’s journey,
he sees how ruthless and cruel Quaritch is
to the Navi.
There are some brief moments where he kind
of bonds with his father and opens up a bit
with him, but that gets drastically overshadowed
later on by the horrifying things Quaritch
does.
Also it feels pretty underdeveloped how Neytiri
was so quick to kill Spider during the hostage
negotiation in the beginning.
The writers kind of drop it and don’t address
it again.
Seems like this would be something that would
heavily affect Spider’s loyalty.
So the ending in which Spider saves Quaritch’s
life seems pretty confusing overall and it
feels like he’s dooming the fate of the
Navi in the process.
Despite the movie giving off the notion that
he’s still loyal to the Navi.
I’m sure a lot of people face-palmed during
this moment and it feels like James Cameron
wants to keep this villain character around.
Although, this will kind of be getting into
the wonky new story mechanics because in theory,
wouldn’t they be able to endlessly bring
back these characters in alien avatars?
Given that they can now suddenly through a
retcon, download the minds of human beings
as if this is Altered Carbon suddenly.
Seems like a crazy macguffin to just breeze
over pretty quickly in the beginning.
Like they can deadass just copy anyone’s
mind now.
What the hell is the point of this dumb orange
goo that they are mining from the brains of
tulkun that halts your aging when you can
just be cloned?
Which the orange goo is also insanely absurd
that an entire vial is only worth 80 million
dollars.
We live in a world currently where there are
ultra billionaires, let alone the future where
these people will become even more obscenely
rich.
Like Bill Gates can buy about thirteen hundred
of those vials right now and can basically
use them as his morning routine face lotion.
So that new mechanic was really sill, but
I don’t see the point of this.
If humans in this story can make Avatars of
aliens, then shouldn’t they be able to do
so for humans?
I would assume that would be at least easier.
So then, what would be the point of buying
age lotion when you can transfer your mind
into a new body?
I know this is something relatively minor
in the grand scheme of things to get caught
up on, but these world-building story elements
don’t add up, and when your world doesn’t
consistently make sense, then it will come
across as faulty.
This wasn’t as much of an issue in the first
Avatar because it didn’t have conflicting
elements.
Unobtanium was kind of a meme but it worked
as a baseline for the antagonists to pursue.
However, in The Way of Water, being able to
easily clone people and copy their minds contradicts
the need for the orange glob of de-aging.
This is a big problem to me because this is
the main objective of the antagonists.
Then going into some other weird plot points
is that the humans now want to colonize Pandora.
This sounds pretty ridiculous because firstly
why would humans pick a planet with no oxygen
and that also has a hostile population that
they will have to fully exterminate to live
in?
Wouldn’t it be easier to pick a different
planet at this ponit?
Like it made sense in the first movie to go
to Pandora because it was rich in unobtanium
and they were just there to mine it, but to
choose to live there seems like an odd choice.
It just feels like James Cameron is forcing
the humans to come back on very slim and unrealistic
motivations, just so that we could have this
conflict.
So reworking their motivations and reasoning
for being there seems like a given and it
can be as simple as there’s no more unobtanium
on earth and they need it on Pandora, and
that’s why they came back.
Not to live there permanently and instead
to essentially wage war on Pandora for all
of its resources.
I know that James Cameron is making a statement
about how the earth is dying and we need to
find a new planet, but when you have the means
of interstellar travel, then surely we’d
have more options than just Pandora.
Then to list off a couple of other weird plot
points are the sea people disappearing halfway
through the third act when the eclipse happens.
And then Jake saying that he needs to protect
the forest Navi clan by leaving and then he
just joins a new clan that he then endangers
with his presence.
Seems like a forced way to get to the sea.
I’m also kind of surprised that the humans
didn’t care at all about the forest clan
and only pursued Jake.
Then one last thing in regard to the script
is that the movie really didn’t need to
be over 3 hours.
A lot of the scenes felt pretty extended and
could have been shortened a little.
Although it is really nice to have some breathtaking
visuals to gawk over.
It’s just that as I said before, you need
to be more productive and have plot progression
that coincides with the spectacle.
The structure of the movie also feels a little
lopsided because the first act was pretty
fast-paced in comparison to the long 2nd act.
It’s pretty apparent that James Cameron
wanted to get to the sea as soon as possible.
Then there’s one scene that could probably
be deleted in which Quaritch’s team wants
to tame Mountain Banshees.
The reason why I say this is because they
don’t really utilize them after this because
they just join the big ship and park them
for the rest of the movie.
Quaritch does briefly use it during the final
act against Jake, but you don’t need that
small moment in an already big action set-piece.
This is why I think that the producers were
scared to stand up to James Cameron because
there’s some fluff here that could have
been cut out considering that the movie is
3 hours and 12 minutes.
I know I’ve been talking about all of the
negatives within the story but there are still
some shining positives.
My favorite parts are definitely the strong
emotional moments between Jake and Neytiri
that really carried the movie at times.
Zoe Saldana in particular really blew me away
with her performance and I’m pretty sad
that she wasn’t in the movie all that much.
Then the whale poaching was so heartbreaking.
The movie really gets you to love the Tulkun
by making them friendly and sentient creatures.
Making the aspect of humans hunting them even
more depressing.
Definitely, a great element in the story that
was kind of tarnished by the orange goo aspect.
Overall, the story for Avatar the Way of Water
feels like a step down in comparison to the
first Avatar which I was kind of surprised
by.
It doesn’t feel as coherent and solid as
the first movie and it felt like the script
needed a little re-working despite being in
development for so long.
But the action was stunning and the VFX will
easily win an oscar with no competition.
Despite the lackluster story, I’d still
give it a 3.5 out of 5 on Letterboxd.
Thank you for watching and let me know what
you thought about Avatar: The Way of Water.